troisième épisode de notre série de
l'été dt 6 6 mo dans laquelle je réponds
aux questions les plus inattendues des
forums santé j'aime beaucoup ce format
donc dites moi dans les commentaires si
ça vous plaît aussi parce que j'ai quand
même bien envie d'en refaire de temps en
temps la dernière fois on avait parlé de
transit et digestion aujourd'hui on va
s'intéresser à un autre sujet très
important le sexe sais pas si vous
connaissez
[Musique]
avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet si
vous me passez l'expression j'ai un
petit truc à vous dire cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par les lots vous les
connaissez sûrement maintenant ils
avaient déjà sponso ma vidéo sur
l'orgasme est évidemment on vous a
encore prévu un petit cadeau que vous
expliquez ça après mais d'abord pour
celles et ceux qui connaissent pas les
lots c'est une marque de sex-toys des
sex-toys haut de gamme qui sont à la
fois agréable à regarder et à utiliser
moi j'aime bien en tout cas mais aussi
fabriqués dans des matériaux robustes et
respectueux de vos muqueuses et de
celles et ceux de vos partenaires
éventuels et c'est quoi la tagline de
dtc prenez soin de vous et prenez soin
des autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien voilà ça colle la safex
ans je veux dire la philosophie de lelo
un match bien avec la mienne en gros
c'est la sexualité fait une partie
importante de notre bien-être et de
notre santé physique et mentale donc on
doit pouvoir en parler comment vous dire
que je suis complètement d'accord avec
ça et comme n'y a pas une sexualité
uniforme a en plus d'en parler ce qui
est bien c'est d'expérimenter tout seul
ou à plusieurs pour apprendre à vous
connaître pour apprendre à connaître
votre nouveau partenaire si vous en avez
ou les deux bah oui parce que tout le
monde aime pas les mêmes choses et c'est
très bien comme ça et chez les lots il
ya de quoi satisfaire tout le monde il
ya de quoi satisfaire le clitoris mais
pas seulement parce que ce sextoy là il
a été conçu pour masser l'intégralité du
corps c'est pour ça qu'il est grand faut
pas avoir peur voilà il s'appelle le
smart world c'est mon préféré
en plus il est hyper doux
[Musique]
mais il ya aussi de quoi satisfaire le
clitoris et le point g en même temps il
ya de quoi satisfaire la prostate celui
là il a une petite télécommande il ya
même de quoi satisfaire ceux qui aiment
bien chanter devant la glace mais là on
s'égare bon bref y'a plein de produits
pour tous les goûts et de toutes les
couleurs il ya de quoi satisfaire tout
le monde vous avez le choix et voilà qui
nous amène à mon petit cadeau pour votre
plus grand plaisir je vous offre 25 % de
réduction sur tous les produits les lots
à une ou deux exceptions près je vous
explique tout ça dans la description de
la vidéo et pour avoir cette réduction
vous avez juste à faire votre choix sur
le site de lelo de passer votre commande
et de taper le code des taux moyens
mnémotechniques dtc comme le nom de ma
chaîne ou comme ce que vous voulez c'est
valable un mois donc jusqu'à fin
septembre 2022 perdez pas de temps vous
avez le lien dans la description donc
vous cliquez et vous utilisez le code
dtc je ne peux pas vous dire mieux voilà
ceci étant dit c'est parti pour la
première question ma copine m'a fait une
fellation il n'y a rien eu d'autre je
n'ai même pas enlever ses avis elle a
ensuite eu ces règles deux fois dans le
même mois avec deux semaines
d'intervalle ce mois ci elle a un retard
de six jours est ce qu'il ya une
possibilité de grossesse bloqué donc sa
part comme ça direct d'abord pour les
règles irrégulières ça arrive il peut y
avoir des raisons à la fois physique et
psychologique si ça rentre dans l'ordre
pas de souci si ça devient de plus en
plus fréquents ça vaut le coup de
consulter ensuite attention petite
précision les vêtements ne sont pas un
moyen de contraception efficace ça me
paraît important de le rappeler parce
que ça va pas être là et puis pour le
coup la grossesse après une fellation
comment dire clairement c'est fait pas
par là que ça se passe la fécondation
c'est la rencontre entre un
spermatozoïde et d'un ovule
alors on voit à peu près comment un
spermatozoïde peut se retrouver dans un
estomac par contre un ovule aucune
chance d'ailleurs de toute façon
l'acidité des sucs gastriques ça vous
irait tout ce petit monde avant même
qu'ils aient le temps d'envisager quoi
que ce soit donc mais pour être tout à
fait complet il faut quand même que je
vous parle d'un cas publiée dans le très
sérieux journal internationale de
gynécologie et d'obstétrique ce cas
c'est celui d'une jeune femme qui vit au
lesotho et qui est tombée enceinte après
une fellation alors vous allez me dire
oui mais peut-être qu'elle a eu aussi un
rapport sexuel avec pénétration vaginale
au cours duquel la fécondation a eu lieu
je sais que vous parlez comme ça et je
vais vous répondre et bien non car cette
jeune femme ne possède pas de vagins
true story elle a une aplasie vaginale
distale c'est à dire que son vagin ne
s'est tout simplement pas développé
alors comment c'est possible cette
histoire hélas c'est arrivé après un
drame après une fellation avec ses
minots s'agit c'est le terme
scientifique pour dire avaler la jeune
femme a reçu plusieurs coups de couteau
au niveau de l'abdomen
c'est le terme scientifique pour dire le
ventre elle a rapidement été opéré et
s'est vite remise sans séquelles mais
neuf mois plus tard pendant l'agression
son estomac a été perforé et il son
contenu s'est répandu dans la cavité
abdominale son contenu c'est à dire
exclusivement du sperme parce que la
jeune femme était à jack d'ailleurs
c'est sûrement pour ça que l'estomac
étaient peu acide et que les
spermatozoïdes ont survécu le temps
qu'ils y ont passé d'ailleurs le
chirurgien il a précisé que l'agression
elle a eu lieu immédiatement après la
semino s'agit donc les spermatozoïdes
ont passé très peu de temps dans les
stands la théorie des médecins qui ont
étudié le cas c'est que les
spermatozoïdes
ils ont fini par arriver au contact d'un
ovaire en pleine relation donc
fécondation sur place et puis hop le
viol a fait son petit road trip jusqu'à
l'utérus et la grossesse est allée
jusqu'à son terme ok je vois bien que
j'aie chier l'ambiance avec cette
histoire alors j'avais prévenu avant et
puis surtout je le répète cette jeune
femme au final elle va bien bon ok on va
quand même faire une petite pause
permettez moi de vous offrir un petit
interlude pour remettre un petit peu de
joie dans vos coeurs avant de poursuivre
érection trop souvent trop souvent
excité dans la rue ou les transports est
ce normal alors déjà je propose que tout
le monde se calme et que tu arrêtes de
crier c'est vrai qu'on te sont
extrêmement tendues l'adulte fleur de
peau alors comme d'habitude ya plein de
trucs qui peuvent expliquer cette
situation si on parle d'un point de vue
purement physique et mécanique le fait
d'être en érection de façon anormalement
prolongée ça s'appelle un priapisme
c'est une maladie c'est douloureux ça
peut être dangereux et ça peut même
aller jusqu'à la nécrose de l'organe
concerné nécrose ça veut dire que ça
devient tout noir et que sa mère mais
surtout ça survient en dehors de toute
excitation sexuelle donc je pense qu'on
peut déjà éliminés cette hypothèse en
l'occurrence pour ce qui est d'être je
cite trop souvent excité là c'est plus
subjectif déjà ça veut dire quoi trop
souvent et puis excité pourquoi
peut-être que la fréquence des rapports
sexuels de cette personne et pas à la
hauteur de cette vidéo peut-être qu'elle
est juste très sensible très réactive
peut-être que cette personne est un
adolescent les hormones tout ça mais
pour répondre à la question il n'y a pas
de normal ou pas normal la seule vraie
question c'est est-ce que ça le handicap
d'être trop souvent excité genre est ce
qu'il le vit mal ou est-ce que ça
l'empêchent de faire des choses qu'ils
devraient faire ou est-ce que parfois il
a des envies irrépressibles de se
masturber par exemple dans ce cas là
c'est peut-être une addiction au sexe
oui ça existe c'est ce qu'on appelle une
addiction s'en produit et ça soigne mais
pour ça il faut consulter évidemment
bonjour je jouais le savoir à qui vous
pensez quand vous vous masturbez que
vous êtes en couple où l'on soit bien
d'accord je ne vais pas répondre à cette
question je voulais juste rappeler un
petit truc ce imaginer des scénarios
tout ça c'est de l'ordre du fantasme
c'est un truc qui vous appartient d'en
couple ou pas couple vous n'êtes jamais
obligé de répondre à cette question et
puis surtout parce que j'imagine que
c'est un petit peu ce qu'il ya derrière
cette question non pensez à quelqu'un
d'autre dans les moments de petits
plaisirs solitaires s'est pas trompé
donc tranquille si vous avez envie de
vous faire du bien en pensant à patronne
boulanger votre voisine ou au père
fouras ça regarde que vous alors dans le
dernier cas là personnellement je
monterai pas trop mais vous faites ce
que vous voulez bonjour alors voilà j'ai
un fantasme sexuel vraiment celle où je
me fais du bien depuis petit uniquement
sur ce fantasme mon fantasme et tout ce
qui concerne le massage cardiaque bouche
à bouche etc ni lait ni les ne m'attire
ça me dégoûte même uniquement mon
fantasme il existe beaucoup de vidéos à
l'intérieur sur sa surtout des vidéos
étasunienne donc je sais que je ne suis
pas le seul mais bon je comprends pas
j'ai l'impression d'être bizarre besoin
de réponses svp merci oui donc on reste
dans le thème en fait la même réponse en
bo1 vos fantasmes c'est votre petit dans
ce rêve donc vous n'êtes pas obligé d'en
parler aux gens comment vous à me voir
là après si vous avez envie vous avez le
droit aussi mais en tout cas vous n'avez
pas à en avoir honte les manoeuvres de
réanimation cardiorespiratoire vous nous
excite la belle a fait un petit
précision quand même il ya deux cas au
moins dans lesquels il faut faire
quelque chose d'abord si vous le vivez
vraiment mal là évidemment ça vaut le
coup d'aller en parler avec une
professionnelle ou un professionnel pour
comprendre pour assumer n'importe le but
c'est que au final ce soit plus un poids
pour vous et puis bien sûr si vous
fantasmez sur des truc glauque genre sur
des trucs illégaux et surtout si vous
avez des pulsions de passage à l'acte à
les consulter avant qu'il soit trop tard
je pense qu'on se comprend
bon ok j'ai encore chez l'ambiance
un picotement vaginale avec le sperme de
mon copain pourquoi sécheresse vaginale
ph du sperme qui peut y avoir plein de
causes différentes à ce genre de
picotement après un rapport sexuel ça
peut effectivement être un problème de
sécheresse vaginale auquel cas il faut
pas hésiter à utiliser du lubrifiant il
y en a plusieurs sortes différentes mais
en l'occurrence l'idéal c'est du
lubrifiant à que
bien sûr
ah que ça veut dire à base d'eau
ça peut aussi être le signe d'une
infection sexuellement transmissible je
vous rappelle que c'est important de se
dépister et de se protéger ça peut être
plein d'autres trucs mais le seul moyen
d'être fixé c'est d'aller faire un tour
chez la gynéco ou celle vidéo mais si
c'est vraiment le contact avec le sperme
qui pose problème et surtout si ça
picote quelle que soit la zone qui est
en contact pensez à l'allergie au sperme
oui ça existe on est même déjà parlé
dans la vidéo sur les accidents sexuelle
et comme pour les autres allergies bas
on peut en développer une à un truc avec
lequel on a déjà été en contact
régulièrement et ça se soigne ça soigne
comme les autres allergies en
désensibilise ans c'est à dire en
injectant sous la peau une petite
quantité de l'allergène c'est à dire une
petite quantité de la substance qui est
la cause de l'allergie
donc voilà c'est rare mais penser
bonjour à tous alors j'ai discuté avec
une amie qui m'a dit de le poster ici à
voir j'aime pas trop parler de moi
sexuellement mais j'ai pas trouvé des
deux tours de moi donc le tente ici
alors j'ai rencontré un gars avec qui je
suis en relation depuis quatre mois
environ c'est un peu nouveau pour moi
car c'est le cinquième cas seulement
après avoir été en couple pas mal de
temps avec deux autres avant je suis pas
habitué à coucher comme ça mais bon
c'est pas ça le sujet effectivement ce
pas le seul le vrai truc c'est plus
intime et je me pose des questions en
fait quand on fait l'amour avec mon
copain actuel j'entends des bruits
souvent ces bruits viennent de moi je me
sens ça ressemble à des paies en fait et
j'ai quasiment jamais connu ça avant
parfois avec quelques excuses avec lui
c'est tout le temps et dans beaucoup de
positions c'est très gênant pour moi car
je n'aime pas ça du tout mais en fait
j'ai l'impression que luce alexis tu car
ça arrive super souvent comme comme si
la exprès quoi alors je sais pas si
c'est un problème qui vient de moi ou de
lui ou de la compatibilité ensemble
c'est vrai qu'il a un sexe très
différent de mes ex relation très long
plus large j'aimerais comprendre ces
bruits en fait et savoir comment les
contrôler svp merci et bien bien bien
bien des pères à gino donc enfin
j'imagine que c'est bien de ça dont par
nos camarades non parce que si on parle
de gaz intestinaux bas on adapte le
régime alimentaire éventuellement un
petit peu de charbon actif et hop
emballé c'est pesé mais là je pense
qu'on parle de paix de fous du foot
de couy fpt comme on dit dans la langue
de britney spears alors première chose
c'est juste de l'air qui rentre dans le
vagin puis qui ressort de l'air ambiant
qui fait du bruit rien de plus donc rien
de grave rien de dangereux et puis
retour rien salle tout va bien ok
personne va être blessé aucun danger
ensuite dont on sait bien ce qui fait
rentrer et ressortir l'air un donc la
responsabilité est partagée si vous
voulez c'est un concerto à quatre mains
c'est une façon de parler alors pourquoi
cette personne on a plus avec son
partenaire actuel qu'avec les précédents
effectivement la forme et les dimensions
de l'outil de son partenaire fait
peut-être que ça fait plus appel d'air
la façon de pratiquer le coït ça peut
jouer aussi peut-être genre le fait de
sortir complètement puis de rentrer par
exemple bon alors de là à dire qu'il le
fait exprès j'avoue j'ai jamais entendu
parler de ça mais bon on sait qu'il ya
tour donc pour ce qui est de contrôler
tout ça on peut toujours faire des
exercices pour muscler son périnée pour
tonifier son vagin ça peut aider des
exercices de kegel par exemple sais pas
si vous connaissez on contracte les
muscles de son périnée si vous savez pas
comment on fait il faut faire comme si
on se retape faire caca vous tenez comme
ça bien contractée pendant une dizaine
de secondes et puis vous relâcher et
puis vous recommencez comme ça à part ce
rsa peut diminuer le phénomène de paix
valent gino donc si vous êtes concerné
et que ça vous gêne pas allez-y mais en
vrai si vous voulez mon avis le mieux
c'est quand même d'assumer le truc parce
que encore une fois c'est normal il n'y
a rien de sale et il n'y a rien de
honteux bonjour j'ai la phobie des
coeurs de palmier quand j'envoie
dessinée sur une boîte de conserve je
supporte mais dès qu'ils sont sortis je
m'enfuis en courant d'une fois j'ai même
bousculé un vieux dans une soirée est
sans rapport avec mon syndrome rocco aux
lardons ou quoi alors j'ai vérifié ça a
bien été postés dans la section
sexualité du forum la phobie des coeurs
de palmier quel rapport s'ils savaient
et des choeurs d'artichaut à la limite
j'aurais pu comprendre mais là vraiment
et puis le syndrome rocco
puisque
attendait le syndrome de rocco ou le
syndrome de coraux parce que ça ça
existe le syndrome de coraux sais je
cite un trouble psychiatrique
habituellement décrit comme un syndrome
spécifiques à certaines cultures
asiatiques se manifestant par une
anxiété intense associé à la crainte
d'une rétractation du pénis dans
l'abdomen qui peut mener à la mort je
vous jure que c'est un vrai truc c'est
soit des cas isolés soit des épidémies
qui ont été attribués à de la viande de
porc frelaté ou à des esprits voleurs de
pénis
voilà donc c'est peut-être de ce
syndrome que parle cette personne parce
que le syndrome de recours je connais
pas a priori j'imagine que ce sera
plutôt l'extrême inverse du coup
après le lien avec les coeurs de palmier
j'avoue je
j'ai bien une idée mais bon voilà à
détester c'est fini voilà détester c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui juste un petit
truc en préparant cette émission je suis
tombé sur un nombre incroyable de
questions sur la sexualité ça parle de
problèmes de libido de problèmes
d'orgasme de troubles de l'érection de
vaginisme de crainte diverses de
complexe de phobies et c'est bien
vraiment beaucoup de sujets qui
mériteraient des vidéos dédiées donc je
pense que je vais en faire un petit peu
régulièrement à partir de maintenant
n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les
commentaires si c'est quelque chose qui
vous intéresseraient on se retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]